A flurry of new
developments in Russia's
invasion of Ukraine.
Inside Russian territory,
officials report shelling in Belgorod.
This is just over the border
from Ukraine.
This is an area
that the Russians have been using
to resupply troops inside Ukraine.
Now, the Ukrainians,
they reported, strike strife
in the junior pro region.
Here we have video
of some of the aftermath.
You can see
what looks like a parking facility here,
largely destroyed the cars there.
And you can see the smoldering
ashes there.
So nearby into Dnipro
in Zapp
Reach, this Africa power plant,
which is right about their power
was off for some time,
but it has now been restored.
That is Europe's largest
nuclear power plant.
You can see the specs here.
Safety continues to be a top concern
for many officials
and perhaps most importantly
at this point,
from a strategic standpoint.
Confusion over the eastern city
of Bath Moot.
Russia says it has seized
control of that city.
Ukraine seems to suggest
they have a potential strategic advantage
there.
With us
now is CNN military
analyst, retired Major General
James Spider Marks.
Spider,
I have a close up here of Bermuda.
You can see the city,
the downtown area right here.
There seems to be broad agreement
that the Russians
have total
or essentially near total control
of the downtown area.
Ukraine says they have
some kind of advantage
because they control
some of the surrounding areas.
Explain how or if
both things can be true.
Well, they absolutely can be true.
John, what you have what you
what you've demonstrated
is that Ukrainians have held
what's called the shoulders,
those flanks around the city,
which means
the Ukrainians can continue to access
block mode as necessary.
They can continue to harass
Russian forces
and the Wagner group as well.
And that gives them some presence there.
But I think when you take a step back
and you look at that
and your description of this as strategic
it is primarily because it gives Russia
the narrative that they're not losing.
Look,
I can tell you right now,
Putin is not winning
He doesn't want to lose.
That's the significance of
when you look at it strategically,
there is very little
that's important
about That's horrible to say
because of the devastation,
the destruction, the death
that the deaths
that have been incurred there.
But there is nothing to be gained
that will alter fundamentally
the strategic outcome
from what we're seeing now.
Why is that?
Spider, can you go into that
a little more?
Again, here's Bermuda.
It's in the east.
It's in the best regional region
where the Russians want total control.
If they now control all of this,
how does not that not impact
what could be this spring offensive from
the Ukrainians coming up
It certainly gives the Russians
an opportunity to maintain
that line of communications
from mainland Russia
all the way down to Crimea right Right.
The significance of Park Moot
is that it is a location exactly as you
as you're describing right now,
which is Putin's objective,
but Moot now has become important
only because
it affects the Russians, flanks
those shoulder operations
as they maneuver
from northeast to southwest.
That's the significant issue right now.
But there are no significant
crossroads railyards,
things that would affect the logistics
and the support of operations,
either for the Ukrainians
trying to reclaim it
or the Russians
trying to enforce
or reinforce
I'm sorry to reinforce their efforts
in the vicinity of Crimea.
What we continue to see,
we believe, from the Ukrainian side,
the Russians claiming attacks
inside Russian territory,
particularly around Belgorod,
that city just over the border.
Why would the Ukrainians
be targeting that
It's important that they
continue to go after the Russians
in Russian territory.
Now, this is the sticking point.
What the Ukrainians need to do
is go
after Russian forces
where they can refit, rest
and then prepare for redeployment.
That's what the
that's what the Ukrainians need to do
so that the Russian soldiers
don't have any form of sanctuary
that give them an opportunity
to relax and rest
and then get ready for it to fight again
and go across the border.
The Ukrainians have got to be very,
very precise.
These should not be civilian targets.
I don't suggest they are.
But to go
after those military targets,
to keep the Russians head down
Spider, as always,
thank you so much for your help.
Retired Major General James Spider Marks.